before 1am that's when several neighbors
they called 911 reporting
hearing multiple gunshots the spot shot
our technology
it was also notified and also officers
patrolling in the area
they heard the gunshots quickly came
over when police arrived at the entrance
of the
villa capri and sherman gardens entrance
they found a black man
in his late 30s shot several times
and then he was transported to umc
trauma and that's where they pronounced
him dead
we're still trying to canvas the area
within it hoping to find some witnesses
who actually observed it there were many
people that heard
the incident but nobody actually has
come forward that has seen the incident
so
again you can do it anonymously through
crime stoppers
metro they of course were searching the
area this morning
looking for surveillance video any
weapons or vehicles that may have been
connected with this incident
and they were out here for several hours
they just cleared out
about a half hour ago but again several
different ways that they were alerted
especially that spot shotter technology
that
seemed very useful in this particular
situation